alternative unis montanes écologie et
solidaire dit m
et la troisième liste à se lancer pour
les élections municipales à montigny le
bretonneux à sa tête en binôme à l'image
des valeurs de collectifs de démocratie
participative qu'elle souhaite défendre
personnellement j'ai rejoint la liste m
montini par les valeurs de collectifs
qu'elle porte et le projet
de transition écologique où on arrive
aujourd'hui dans la société il faut
changer le monde
il faut enfin moi c'est mon envie c'est
de changer le monde et on peut commencer
à l'échelon local parce que c'est là
qu'on peut agir concrètement pas
d'étiquette politique ni aucun soutien
ne sera affiché la sensibilité est tout
de même à gauche et écologistes règles
électorales obligent divin gasc sera
numéro un du binôme et donc tête de
liste élue par les autres membres du
collectif on se présente un binôme tête
de liste et ça c'est important
et dans tout à notre action municipale
l'idée c'est de construire des binômes
avec des gens qui travaillent ensemble
et pas des décisions ultracentralisée
entre les mains d'une personne
transition écologique avec la notion
d'économie sociale et solidaire
démocratie participative avec l'envié de
dynamiser les conseils de quartier et
solidarité sont les trois grands piliers
du programme co construit au cours
d'assemblées citoyennes une majorité des
gens qui sont sur cette liste des gens
de gauche
pas tous et ça c'était important pour
nous l'ouverture c'était la capacité à
s'ouvrir
d'abord si on n'est pas capable entre
nous d'être un minimum ouvert on n'est
pas capable de convaincre une majorité
de nos montagnes notre ambition nous
c'est quand même nous de remporter
l'élection municipale
la liste m poursuit ses actions de
tractage dans la ville et de nombreuses
réunions publiques sont programmées par
quartier prochaine date le 31 janvier à
la maison de quartier henri matisse